- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
Je tiens en votre nom à souhaiter
la bienvenue à madame la députée
de la 1re circonscription du
Vaucluse, élue le 4 juin en
remplacement de M.
Joris Hébrard.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première question va être posée
par Nadège Abomangoli.
- Nadège Abomangoli: Madame la
Première ministre, 15 journées de
mobilisations massives,
historiques et populaires,
organisées par un front syndical
uni, solidaire et déterminé.
Vous pensiez valider la volonté du
peuple et, six mois plus tard, le
voilà toujours prêt à batailler.
L'enjeu est clair: nous voulons
abroger votre réforme des
retraites car elle condamne tous
les travailleurs à deux ans de
travail de plus et à des retraites
plus basses.
Elle condamne les carrières
hachées par les discriminations,
par les exploiteurs.
Elle condamne davantage les
femmes, les personnes LGBT, les
personnes en situation de
handicap, les travailleurs
étrangers.
Elle condamne les précaires,
celles et ceux qui subissent mais
ne baissent jamais les bras.
Vous agissez de manière
autoritaire pour imposer cette
réforme et cela vous conduit au
pire.
Vous bafouez la séparation des
pouvoirs en décidant de ce qui
peut être débattu ou non, en
muselant l'opposition.
Vous remettez en cause le droit
d'amendement des députés.
Vous vous dites garante de la
démocratie, mais qui croyez-vous
tromper?
Vos magouilles causeront votre
perte.
Vous accompagnez l'agonie de la Ve
République.
Vous exécutez la volonté d'un
homme seul qui veut soumettre le
peuple.
Notre peuple est debout et digne.
Jamais vous ne le mettrez à
genoux.
Pour cette raison, vous avez déjà
perdu.
La volonté du peuple est ainsi.
Tôt ou tard, nous abrogerons cette
réforme.
Allez-vous écouter le peuple et
renoncer à cette réforme injuste
et injustifiée?
Allez-vous laisser le Parlement
voter?
Allez-vous admettre votre défaite
morale et politique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
députée, vous avez dit que la
réforme n'apporterait que des
effets négatifs.
C'est pourtant cette réforme qui
va permettre au système de
protection sociale de subsister et
donc de garantir aux générations
qui viennent une pension de
retraite.
C'est cette réforme qui va
permettre de revaloriser la
pension des retraités.
C'est cette réforme qui va
permettre de mieux prendre en
compte les carrières longues, et
notamment de mieux aider ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 18
ans.
C'est cette réforme qui va donner
des droits nouveaux aux femmes,
notamment celles qui travaillent
toute leur vie, et qui vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'une
majoration de leur pension dès
lors qu'elles auront atteint l'âge
légal.
C'est cette réforme qui va
permettre de garantir à ceux qui
sont les plus fragiles d'avoir une
retraite, de pouvoir être
protégés.
Ce ne sont pas les plus riches qui
ont besoin d'un système de
retraite et d'un système de
protection sociale.
Ce sont les plus fragiles.
La responsabilité, c'est de
résorber le déficit.
La responsabilité, c'est de sauver
le système de retraite, et c'est
cette majorité qui le fait.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
députée?
- Nadège Abomangoli: Je ne
m'attendais à rien, mais je suis
quand même déçue.
D'abord, je m'adressais à la
présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale.
Je vous invite à ne pas écouter ce
gouvernement qui mène le pays
droit dans le mur et à défendre
l'Assemblée nationale le 8 juin,
lors de l'examen du texte du
groupe LIOT pour abroger la
réforme des retraites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous dites que
vous ne vous attendiez à rien et
que vous étiez pourtant déçue.
Vous avez oublié de rappeler que
la commission des Affaires
sociales avait voté.
Vous avez perdu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
Madame la députée, lorsque je
préside les questions au
gouvernement, il est d'usage que
je ne prenne pas part au débat.
Je vous remercie de ne pas
m'interpeller.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher, pour
le groupe LIOT.
- Bertrand Pancher: L'usage
généralisé par le gouvernement
d'outils d'obstruction, les
articles 47.1, 44.2, 44.3, 49.3 à
l'Assemblée nationale et 38 au
Sénat, pour faire adopter votre
réforme des retraites injuste,
sans véritable vote, témoigne d'un
détournement manifeste et inédit
de notre démocratie.
Après ces procédures que vous avez
cyniquement utilisées pour
bâillonner le Parlement, une
première sous la Ve République,
vous avez ajouté à la crise
sociale une crise
institutionnelle.
Vous deviez apaiser, mais vous
avez jeté de l'huile sur le feu.
nous avez insultés en nous
traitant d'irresponsables et de
menteurs.
Vous vous êtes même érigée en
membre du Conseil constitutionnel,
ce que vous n'êtes pas, en
effaçant la séparation des
pouvoirs.
Je voulais solennellement, madame
la Première ministre, vous mettre
en garde ainsi que les présidents
de groupe qui cautionnent cette
funeste stratégie qui va créer une
jurisprudence, empêcher désormais
les groupes parlementaires de
déposer des propositions de lois
qui auront le moindre impact
financier.
Je voulais vous rappeler l'article
3 de notre Constitution: la
souveraineté appartient au peuple
français, qui la délègue à ses
représentants, nous, les députés,
ainsi que l'article 24: le
Parlement vote les lois.
Nous votons les lois.
Le général de Gaulle expliquait
que notre Constitution, c'est des
institutions et une pratique.
Vous ne respectez pas ces bonnes
pratiques.
Vous ne respectez même pas le père
de la Ve République.
La démocratie est notre bien le
plus précieux.
Notre groupe et de nombreux autres
députés sur nos bancs veulent la
préserver.
Madame la Première ministre, quand
allez-vous apaiser notre pays, en
laissant enfin les députés voter
la loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher, vous
portez à son paroxysme l'art du
paradoxe.
Premier paradoxe: devant les
Français, vous avez soutenu des
candidats à la présidentielle qui
défendaient la retraite à 65 ans.
Depuis quelques mois, vous êtes le
porte-voix d'une alliance
contre-nature, de La France
Insoumise au Rassemblement
National, hostile à toute mesure
permettant de garantir le
financement de nos retraites.
Deuxième paradoxe: ce sont vos
alliés de la NUPES qui, sur
instruction du leader de La France
Insoumise, ont sciemment empêché
l'Assemblée de débattre et de
voter sur le coeur de la réforme.
Vous prétendez maintenant, avec
cette proposition de loi, que ce
débat pourrait se tenir en
quelques heures.
Monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher, vous le savez, et
monsieur le député Charles de
Courson, grand défenseur de la
rigueur budgétaire, le sait aussi,
votre proposition de loi est
inconstitutionnelle.
Elle aggraverait lourdement les
charges publiques, réduirait les
recettes et démonterait
frontalement l'article 40 de notre
Constitution.
Avec vos alliés insoumis, vous
persévérez dans une deuxième
attaque à notre Constitution: le
contrôle de l'irrecevabilité, qui
a été dévoyée à des fins
uniquement partisanes.
Aujourd'hui, dans une nouvelle
atteinte au principe même de notre
démocratie, vous prétendez ignorer
un vote clair et net en commission
des Affaires sociales, qui a
abrogé le premier article de votre
proposition de loi.
Cette proposition de loi sera
débattue jeudi en séance publique.
Je ne vais ni anticiper, ni
préempter ces débats à venir, mais
ils doivent avoir lieu dans le
cadre fixé par notre Constitution.
Violer la Constitution, c'est
attenter aux droits même des
citoyens.
La démagogie permet de faire les
gros titres, mais elle conduit aux
déceptions, aux colères et au
rejet de la politique comme de nos
institutions.
Alors, respectez la Constitution,
respectez les 175 heures de débats
parlementaires, respectez le vote
des députés en commission,
monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher.
Mettez enfin vos actes en
cohérence avec vos propos.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher?
- Bertrand Pancher: Madame la
Première ministre, vous deviez
apaiser le pays, vous continuez à
jeter de l'huile sur le feu.
Tout ça n'est pas responsable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Bergé pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
"Ca a commencé par des brimades sur
mon poids.
En classe, je recevais des stylos,
des coups de compas dans le dos.
Je me prenais des gifles et des
insultes.
Pendant six ans, je n'ai parlé à
personne.
J'avais trop honte, j'avais trop
peur.
Et puis, j'ai décidé d'en finir.
J'ai acheté 1 litre d'alcool à
brûler, je l'ai répandu sur mes
vêtements et je me suis mis le
feu.
J'avais 16 ans."
Ces mots sont ceux de Jonathan,
victime devenue figure de la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire et
décédé en août dernier et dont je
veux ici saluer la mémoire et le
combat.
Applaudissements
Son combat doit être le nôtre.
Ces drames individuels sont aussi
des drames collectifs.
Le suicide de Lindsay, qui a mis
fin à ses jours à 13 ans, en est
un.
Je veux en notre nom à tous lui
rendre hommage et adresser nos
condoléances à sa famille et à ses
amis, mais aussi lui adresser nos
excuses.
Ces enfants sont nos enfants.
Ils ont mis fin à leurs jours à
l'âge de 10 ans, pour que le
harcèlement cesse.
Ces enfants, ce sont nos enfants,
les enfants de la République.
Qui aurait dû les protéger?
Nous tous.
Nous, les adultes, la communauté
éducative, les autres élèves, ceux
qui voient mais se taisent par
crainte des représailles, nous les
parents, car si un enfant est
harcelé, cela veut bien dire qu'il
y a des brutes pour le harceler.
Nous l'Etat, par le travail
implacable de nos forces de
l'ordre et de la justice, puisque
nous avons justement créé un délit
de harcèlement scolaire.
Nous tous, pour être à l'écoute,
pour voir les signaux, pour leur
permettre de parler, pour ne
jamais prendre à la légère la
douleur d'un enfant.
Parce que ça commence toujours par
une première insulte, une première
humiliation, une première gifle.
Madame la Première ministre, quels
mots voulez-vous adresser aux
parents endeuillés?
Quelles actions pour que plus
aucun parent n'ait à connaître un
pareil drame?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Aurore Bergé, les mots
que vous venez de lire sont
déchirants.
Le harcèlement est un fléau qui
mine le quotidien de milliers de
jeunes et cause trop souvent des
drames: la détresse, la dépression
et, parfois même, le suicide.
Le décès de Lindsay en est un
terrible exemple.
Je veux ici dire toute ma
solidarité et mon soutien à sa
famille et à ses amis.
Oui, le harcèlement peut tuer, et
c'est intolérable.
Madame la présidente Aurore Bergé,
je connais votre engagement
ancien, résolu et constant dans la
lutte contre le harcèlement.
Je sais également qu'il est
largement partagé sur tous les
bancs de cet hémicycle, car sur
une question si grave, il ne peut
pas y avoir de clivage.
Nos écoles, nos collèges, nos
lycées doivent être des lieux de
savoir et d'ouverture contre
l'ignorance et les préjugés, des
lieux où chacun est protégé.
Alors, nous agissons.
Dès 2019, nous avons expérimenté,
sur la base du volontariat, le
programme de lutte contre le
harcèlement Phare.
C'est un protocole de prise en
charge, avec des élèves
ambassadeurs dans chaque
établissement et avec la
sensibilisation des parents comme
des professeurs.
Ce programme, le ministre de
l'Education nationale Pap Ndiaye
l'a rendu obligatoire à la rentrée
2022 dans toutes les écoles et
dans tous les collèges.
Je connais son engagement, qui est
aussi le mien, mais nous devons
aller plus loin.
Nous allons faire de la lutte
contre le harcèlement la priorité
absolue de la rentrée 2023.
Nous allons étendre le programme
Phare aux lycées.
Nous allons désigner dès la
rentrée, dans chaque collège, un
adulte référent dans la lutte
contre le harcèlement.
Nous allons protéger davantage les
élèves victimes en primaire en
ouvrant par décret la possibilité
d'écarter d'une école un élève
auteur de harcèlement.
Nous rendrons obligatoire la
formation des personnels contre le
harcèlement.
Nous augmenterons les moyens des
plates-formes d'alerte et
d'écoute.
Enfin, j'ai demandé au ministre de
l'Intérieur, au ministre de la
Justice et au ministre du
Numérique d'appuyer le ministre de
l'Education nationale afin d'être
plus efficace dans la prévention
et les sanctions contre le
harcèlement, notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux.
Madame la présidente Aurore Bergé,
tout acte de harcèlement est
intolérable.
Nous ne devons rien laisser
passer.
Ensemble, continuons à nous
mobiliser pour protéger notre
jeunesse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la Première
ministre.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Marine Le Pen pour le
Rassemblement National.
- Marine Le Pen: Madame la
Première ministre, la fraude aux
prestations sociales est une
réalité vécue par les Français.
Elle brise le consentement à
l'impôt, casse la confiance dans
l'action publique, sape la foi
dans notre contrat social.
Surtout, elle condamne à terme le
financement de notre protection
sociale.
La Cour des comptes, en 2019 et
2020, a tenté de chiffrer les
fraudes sociales, j'ai bien dit
"tenté".
Elles seraient de 10 à 25
milliards d'euros.
Elles relèvent en particulier des
cartes Vitale en surnombre,
qu'elle estime à plus de 3
millions.
L'IGF compte en 2022 plus de 73
millions d'assurés sociaux pour un
peu de 67 millions d'habitants.
La direction de la Sécurité
sociale explique que tout va bien.
7 millions de cartes Vitale en
trop appartiendraient à des
personnes décédées ou qui ont
quitté le territoire.
La carte Vitale numérique
fluidifierait le dispositif.
La fraude serait minime, selon ses
dires, et la carte Vitale
biométrique serait trop coûteuse.
Bref, il serait urgent de ne rien
faire.
Pourtant, les cartes Vitale
circulent à foison et ne sont pas
forcément utilisées par leurs
bénéficiaires légitimes.
Quant aux professionnels de santé,
ils ne vérifient pas les
identités.
Les cartes Vitale prêtées, les
usurpations d'identité font partie
du paysage.
Seule la carte Vitale biométrique
peut y remédier.
Pourtant, lors de la crise
sanitaire, le gouvernement n'avait
pas fait preuve de naïveté
lorsqu'une personne utilisait le
pass vaccinal d'un tiers, elle
s'exposait à une amende de 1000
euros.
La réalité est que la biométrie
est l'unique moyen de réserver la
prise en charge des soins aux
seules personnes légitimes.
Nous devons écouter les mises en
garde de la Cour comptes et de
l'Inspection générale des
finances.
Ce sont les personnes modestes qui
souffrent en premier lieu des
difficultés financières de la
protection sociale, lesquelles
entraînent mécaniquement déserts
médicaux et des remboursements.
Allez-vous enfin aller au-delà des
mots?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Le Pen, je vous le
confirme, notre modèle social est
au coeur de notre pacte
républicain.
Frauder, c'est spolier les
Français qui contribuent
honnêtement, c'est fragiliser le
service public et c'est mettre en
cause ce pacte social.
C'est bien pourquoi le ministre en
charge des comptes publics a
annoncé, ces dernières semaines,
un plan d'action globale contre la
fraude fiscale et contre la fraude
sociale.
Je vous confirme que nous sommes
déterminés à agir contre cette
fraude fiscale, avec des moyens
supplémentaires, notamment 1500
personnels de plus, avec une
augmentation des moyens techniques
de 25%.
Nous renforçons également les
sanctions, avec un nouveau délit
pénal, des travaux d'intérêt
général pour les fraudeurs
condamnés à une peine d'amende.
Comme il s'agit souvent d'un
phénomène international, nous
voulons initier une COP fiscale.
Nous agissons aussi, nous
recrutons 1000 agents
supplémentaires, nous investissons
1 milliard d'euros pour moderniser
nos systèmes d'information.
Nous renforçons à la fois le
contrôle de ceux qui ont droit à
des prestations, comme des
professionnels.
Je vous remercie, madame la
présidente Le Pen, de m'avoir
donné l'occasion de redire notre
détermination et les moyens que
nous mobilisons.
S'agissant des cartes Vitale, je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas
entendu les déclarations du
ministre en charge des comptes
publics, car il se trouve que nous
avons naturellement pris en compte
l'alerte sur les cartes Vitale
surnuméraires.
Ces cartes Vitale ont été
désactivées.
Il en reste aujourd'hui quelques
centaines.
Vous avez un pouvoir de contrôle,
donc je vous invite à vous en
saisir.
Ces cartes Vitale ont été
désactivées, et par ailleurs, nous
partageons aussi le souhait de
pouvoir assurer que chaque
bénéficiaire d'une carte Vitale
est bien l'utilisateur de la carte
Vitale.
C'est pourquoi le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre en
charge des comptes publics
travaillent conjointement pour
rapprocher la carte Vitale et les
titres d'identité.
Donc vous voyez, je vous remercie
de m'avoir donné l'occasion de
redire la détermination du
gouvernement à lutter contre la
fraude fiscale et la fraude
sociale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Inaki Echaniz.
- Inaki Echaniz: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
j'aurais pu reprendre mot pour mot
la question que j'ai moi-même
posée le 26 juillet dernier.
J'interrogeais alors les ministres
de l'Economie et du Logement sur
la spéculation immobilière qui
frappe dans bon nombre de nos
territoires.
Depuis, 10 mois ont passé et la
crise du logement ne fait que
s'aggraver.
L'ensemble des acteurs du logement
étaient suspendus aux annonces du
gouvernement dans le cadre du CNR
sur le logement.
Mais beaucoup de bruit pour rien.
Vous passez à côté de vos propres
ambitions.
Si ce CNR a permis de mettre la
question du logement au coeur de
l'actualité, les réponses que vous
apportez sont insuffisantes ou
décevantes.
Ce n'est pas le constat d'un
simple élu d'opposition mais celui
d'une majorité d'acteurs de la
fédération du bâtiment à la
Fondation Abbé Pierre.
Difficile d'égaler un tel
naufrage, et ce n'est pas moi qui
le dis mais un ancien ministre du
Logement.
Construction, rénovation, accès à
la propriété, spéculation,
encadrement des loyers de
tourisme: les enjeux sont
multiples et mériteraient une
vraie loi de programmation.
A cela, vous préférez répondre par
une kyrielle de nouvelles
réflexions superposées à des
rapports eux-mêmes héritiers de
multiples concertations.
A cela, vous préférez faire 2
milliards d'euros d'économies
encore une fois, en sacrifiant le
prêt à taux zéro.
Il est temps de prendre votre
responsabilité sur ce sujet de
préoccupation quotidienne pour les
Français.
Madame la ministre, il y a des
dossiers qui vous semblent
prioritaires, comme la réforme des
retraites dont personne ne veut,
le contournement des pouvoirs
parlementaires, dont nous avons
encore une brillante illustration.
Si vous mettiez autant d'énergie à
traiter le sujet du logement qu'à
empêcher les députés de voter, les
constats seraient bien différents.
A côté de votre manque de
clairvoyance se pose la question
de votre cohérence.
Le logement occupe une place
centrale.
Quand débattrons-nous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Monsieur le
député Inaki Echaniz, oui, le CNR,
hier, s'est conclu en présence de
madame la Première ministre, que
je remercie.
Non, le logement ne fait pas
partie des grands oubliés du
gouvernement, ni du gouvernement
précédent.
J'en veux pour preuve le plan
logement, d'abord, qui a été lancé
par le président de la République
et le gouvernement précédent et
qui a permis de mettre à l'abri
440.000 personnes sous le
quinquennat précédent.
J'en veux pour preuve le
doublement de l'action de l'ANRU
qui est passée de 5 milliards à la
fin du quinquennat socialiste à 12
milliards à la fin du quinquennat
précédent.
J'en veux pour preuve le lancement
de MaPrimeRénov'.
Les annonces de madame la Première
ministre hier sont à la hauteur
des besoins et seront complétées
dans les jours qui viennent.
Elles sont à la hauteur des
besoins, parce que nous avons
préservé le prêt à taux zéro pour
accéder au logement dans les zones
tendues, et donc permettre des
logements abordables.
Nous avons le souhait de relancer
de manière massive le bail
solidaire qui est un moyen
d'accéder au logement pour les
plus fragiles.
Je m'étonne que vous souteniez le
Pinel, qui est un outil pour les
multi-propriétaires, alors qu'à
l'inverse, nous soutenons le
logement intermédiaire, qui est un
bon un outil d'accession à la
location pour les classes moyennes
et pour permettre du mouvement
dans le parc HLM.
Enfin, j'en terminerai avec le
pacte de confiance que nous allons
conclure avec les HLM, avec la
nécessité de produire plus et de
rénover, parce que la rénovation
est au coeur de notre action.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à Charles
Sitzenstuhl.
- Charles Sitzenstuhl: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, ma
question s'adresse au ministre
porte-parole du gouvernement.
Jeudi dernier, la commission
d'enquête relative aux ingérences
étrangères a voté le rapport de
notre collègue Constance Le Grip,
qui sera publié dans quelques
jours.
Nous savons tous dans quelles
circonstances cette commission
d'enquête a été commandée par les
apprentis sorciers du
Rassemblement National.
Personne ici n'a été dupe de cette
tentative d'instrumentalisation de
notre Assemblée par une extrême
droite qui voulait se blanchir de
ses liaisons avec la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine.
Bien mal leur a pris tant le
retour de flamme semble encore
douloureux aujourd'hui.
Pendant les cinq mois d'auditions,
nous avons assisté au meilleur
comme au pire.
Le meilleur, ce fut toutes les
personnes qui ont rendu compte des
tentatives de déstabilisation de
notre démocratie venant notamment
de la Chine, de la Russie et du
Moyen-Orient.
Qu'en pense le gouvernement?
Le pire, ce furent les
confirmations des liens tout
particuliers de l'extrême droite
soi-disant patriote avec une
puissance étrangère, la Russie de
monsieur Poutine.
Des liens intenses et anormaux
car, oui, de multiples auditions
ont confirmé les connexions entre
la galaxie lepéniste et le système
de Moscou.
Lors de sa propre audition, madame
Le Pen a une nouvelle fois propagé
la propagande du Kremlin et
réitéré son soutien à l'invasion
russe de la Crimée en 2014,
fameuse année où le Front National
contractait son emprunt de 9
millions d'euros auprès d'une
banque en partie russe.
Comment le gouvernement juge les
menaces d'ingérence pesant sur
notre démocratie?
Comment mieux protéger notre
indépendance nationale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Monsieur le député Charles
Sitzenstuhl, une ingérence
étrangère en France, c'est comme
une poupée russe.
D'abord, saper les intérêts
français à l'étranger, Poutine le
fait.
Ensuite, pratiquer la
désinformation à grande échelle,
Poutine le fait.
Enfin, interférer dans une
élection en investissant sur un
candidat qui vous serait
favorable, la question à laquelle
votre commission d'enquête devra
répondre, c'est: Poutine l'a-t-il
fait?
Dans quel but Poutine ferait-il de
l'ingérence en France?
Pas par amour de nos valeurs
républicaines, de notre art de
vivre à la française.
A l'évidence, ce serait pour
affaiblir la France et l'Europe.
Poupée russe et donc aussi cheval
de Troie.
Vous m'interrogez sur les liens
que vous suspectez entre
l'ingérence russe et le
Rassemblement National.
La lecture de votre rapport de
commission d'enquête sera sans
doute éclairante.
Mais avant cela, les liens entre
le Rassemblement National de
madame Le Pen et la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine sont connus.
Elle y est allée quatre fois en
cinq ans.
Elle n'a jamais caché son
admiration pour le dirigeant
russe, allant jusqu'à afficher son
visage souriant sur un tract de sa
campagne présidentielle.
Pour le patriotisme, on repassera.
Etait-ce dans ce cas-là de la part
de madame Le Pen de la naïveté?
Vous juriez, madame Le Pen, que
jamais Vladimir Poutine
n'envahirait l'Ukraine, trois
semaines seulement avant que
l'invasion ne débute.
Etait-ce du cynisme?
Parce que pour vous, la fin
justifie les moyens, et
qu'importe, puisqu'une fois
présidente, vous seriez redevable
à celui qui aurait contribué à
vous faire élire.
Puisque monsieur Poutine est votre
banquier, c'est donc que pour lui,
vous êtes un placement.
Moi, je crois que c'était du
cynisme.
J'en parle au passé puisque
monsieur Poutine a désormais
disparu des tracts du
Rassemblement National, mais
personne n'est dupe.
Poupée russe, cheval de Troie mais
aussi pantin de monsieur Poutine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Marc Le Fur.
- Marc Le Fur: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, une
grave crise du logement est devant
nous.
Vous étiez hier devant les
professionnels de l'immobilier et
de la construction.
Vos propos ont énormément déçu.
Cette déception est partagée par
tous, de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
aux artisans de la fédération du
bâtiment en passant par le monde
HLM.
Vos propositions ne sont pas à la
hauteur de la crise qui touche ce
secteur.
En supprimant le dispositif de la
loi Pinel, vous tuez
l'investissement locatif privé.
En supprimant le prêt à taux zéro
sur la construction neuve sur 90%
du territoire, vous portez
préjudice aux petites villes et
aux villes moyennes et vous
accentuez la fracture de notre
pays.
En multipliant les normes et en
réduisant les aides, vous
interdisez l'accès à la propriété
aux classes moyennes.
Vous organisez donc leur
déclassement.
La propriété d'une résidence est
souvent une sécurité pour
leurs vieux jours.
90% des Français aspirent à vivre
dans une maison individuelle.
Notre président de groupe Olivier
Marleix vous l'a dit: "Il faut
mettre un moratoire sur le zéro
artificialisation net."
Nos maires savent que c'est en
train de figer complètement le
développement des communes.
Sortez de cette culture de gauche
qui rejette l'accession à la
propriété et qui refuse la maison
individuelle et prenez des mesures
d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Monsieur le député Marc Le Fur,
oui, il y a une crise du logement
et nous le savons et nous y
travaillons.
Cette crise est multifactorielle
et ne saura se résoudre qu'avec de
l'argent public.
Je vous pensais plus attentif aux
deniers publics.
Il faut résoudre cette crise du
logement ensemble.
C'est le sens du conseil national
de la rénovation que nous avons
mis en place.
Nous avons décidé de permettre à
la Caisse des Dépôts habitat
d'acheter 17.000 logements et de
contribuer à la relance de la
promotion immobilière.
Dans le cadre de la convention
quinquennale, qui sera signée dans
quelques jours, nous avons permis
l'acquisition de 30.000 logements
qui permettront la relance de la
promotion immobilière.
La promotion immobilière produit
de l'habitat privé et de l'habitat
social.
Nous faisons le pari du logement
intermédiaire et vous devriez être
à nos côtés pour promouvoir le
logement intermédiaire, qui permet
le lien entre l'emploi et le
logement.
Nous faisons le pari du bail réel
solidaire qui permettra
l'accession à la propriété aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
intermédiaires à Paris, que l'on
sait déjà gagnantes.
Nous savons qu'il ne faut pas
renvoyer le Français vers le
surendettement.
C'est un risque et je suis bien
placé pour savoir le drame des
copropriétés dégradées.
La copropriété est une bonne
solution si les personnes ont les
moyens de rembourser leurs prêts à
la banque et leurs charges de
copropriété.
Nous faisons le pari massif de la
rénovation.
80% des logements qui existent
sont déjà là et c'est en rénovant
massivement le logement que nous
réussirons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Marc Le Fur?
- Marc Le Fur: Monsieur le
ministre, selon un sondage IFOP,
90% des Français aspirent à vivre
dans une maison individuelle.
Sortez de votre bulle!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Olivier Klein: Personne ne nie
la qualité résidentielle des zones
pavillonnaires.
Il faut les respecter et continuer
à les accompagner.
Nous le faisons avec
MaPrimeRénov'.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je passe la parole à monsieur le
président Moetai Brotherson, que
je voudrais féliciter pour son
élection à la présidence de la
Polynésie française.
Applaudissements
C'est sa dernière question au
gouvernement donc il aura un
traitement de faveur et il pourra
reprendre la parole afin de faire
ses adieux à l'Assemblée.
Vous avez la parole.
- Moetai Brotherson: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Armées.
La Polynésie française, c'est 5
millions de kilomètres carrés,
mais en termes de contrôle aérien,
c'est 12 millions de kilomètres
carrés.
Cette navigation aérienne est
contrôlée par les services
territoriaux et par les services
de l'Etat, qui sont confrontés à
un paradoxe.
Le seul radar monopulse qui est
sur l'île est en cours de
démantèlement.
Il va être remplacé par
l'utilisation de satellites,
couplés à des équipements
embarqués sur les aéronefs.
Ce mode de fonctionnement est tout
à fait efficace.
Sauf que l'ensemble des aéronefs
civils équipés sont les seuls
aéronefs équipés.
Ce ne sont pas ceux de l'armée.
Cela pose un problème pour la
circulation aérienne en Polynésie.
Ces bâtiments de l'armée sont
souvent amenés à faire des
évacuations sanitaires, à faire
des projections sur le territoire,
et on est aujourd'hui dans
l'incapacité de suivre
efficacement leurs mouvements.
Que compte faire le ministère des
Armées pour résoudre ce paradoxe?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Brotherson.
Le contrôle de la circulation
aérienne à Tahiti est actuellement
assuré par un radar qui sera
prochainement remplacé par un
système satellitaire qui équipe
tous les avions civils.
Les aéronefs militaires, en
revanche, obéissent à des règles
spécifiques pour des questions de
sécurité.
Nous sommes conscients de l'enjeu
que vous soulevez et le ministère
de l'Intérieur et des outre-mer se
saisira du sujet.
A l'heure où vous quittez votre
mandat de parlementaire et la
présidence de la délégation aux
outre-mer, je voudrais tout
d'abord vous féliciter pour votre
victoire aux élections en
Polynésie française.
Il pourrait paraître étonnant que
la Première ministre de la
République salue l'élection d'un
responsable politique aux
vues aussi éloignées des siennes
sur un sujet aussi majeur que
l'indépendance d'un territoire de
la République, mais je connais en
vous un parlementaire profondément
respectueux, un opposant ferme
mais attaché au débat démocratique
et toujours prêt au dialogue.
C'est aussi le cas de nombre de
vos collègues.
Nos choix politiques sont
profondément éloignés mais nos
attachements aux valeurs de la
démocratie et de la République
nous rassembleront toujours.
Alors, monsieur le président, vous
avez depuis un an fait vivre la
délégation aux outre-mer avec une
grande maîtrise, en travaillant
avec des territoires et des
cultures politiques diverses.
Les attentes de nos compatriotes
ultramarins sont immenses.
Nous serons au rendez-vous.
Il reste beaucoup de travail.
Au-delà de l'engagement du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer et du ministre délégué
aux outre-mer, tout bon
gouvernement y prend part.
Je réunirai dans quelques semaines
un comité interministériel dédié
aux outre-mer afin de prendre des
solutions d'urgence, mais aussi à
moyen terme.
Nous espérons pouvoir avoir, avec
le gouvernement de la Polynésie
française et vous-même, des
échanges sereins, concrets,
répondant aux attentes des
Polynésiens.
Vous avez eu des mots clairs au
lendemain de votre élection pour
dire que rien ne serait pire que
des débats précipités ou
superficiels.
J'adhère à cette approche.
Les questions qui se posent sont
majeures.
Nous ne chercherons pas à les
contourner, mais nous devons
prendre le temps de converger sur
une méthode.
A travers vous, je veux enfin
saluer l'ensemble des
parlementaires ultramarins et des
habitants de la Polynésie
française.
Nous aurons l'occasion de nous
revoir rapidement pour travailler
au développement et à la
prospérité de ce magnifique
territoire du Pacifique.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le président Brotherson?
- Moetai Brotherson: Je vous
remercie de vos mots très gentils,
madame la Première ministre.
Le 12 mai dernier, j'ai
effectivement été élu président de
la Polynésie française.
C'est une trajectoire de vie que
je n'avais pas prévue.
Le petit garçon qui surfait et
usait ses fonds de culottes sur
les bancs du collège ne
s'attendait pas à siéger parmi
vous et encore moins à devenir
président de la Polynésie.
La vie, après tout, c'est ce qui
arrive quand on fait des plans.
En tout cas, depuis mon premier
mandat en 2017, j'ai appris à
découvrir cette maison
prestigieuse, ses couloirs chargés
d'histoire, ses murs qui, s'ils
pouvaient parler, nous
raconteraient encore plus
d'histoires.
J'ai appris à découvrir des hommes
et des femmes tous attachés aux
valeurs de la République et de la
démocratie.
S'il est toujours aujourd'hui
difficile de comprendre votre
passion du brouhaha...
Applaudissements
Passion partagée sur tous les
bancs de manière cyclique et
périodique, j'avoue que j'ai
toujours été impressionné par la
ferveur des débats et je pense que
vous avez chacun vos convictions
chevillées au corps.
Cette Assemblée est représentative
du peuple français dans sa
diversité.
Les outre-mer sont là également
pour rappeler que cette France
n'est pas qu'hexagonale.
Elle a une géométrie plus vaste
que le simple hexagone.
Une géométrie que l'on a parfois
tendance à oublier ici.
Je souhaite que dans le futur,
cette dimension ultramarine soit
mieux intégrée dans les réflexions
dès la conception de nos lois,
qu'on ne se pose pas la question a
posteriori de ce qu'on fait des
outre-mer dans la loi qui vient
d'être votée.
C'est le voeu que je formule.
Si l'on se penche un peu sur
l'étymologie du terme
"gouvernement" on voit que ça
vient du latin qui veut dire
"tenir le gouvernail, naviguer,
piloté".
Je voulais partager avec vous,
pour finir, avec cette notion:
chez nous, "gouvernement", c'est
le même mot que "paix".
Applaudissements
...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Hendrik
Davi.
- Hendrik Davi: Chers collègues,
Parcoursup est devenu synonyme
d'angoisse.
L'accès à l'enseignement supérieur
est aujourd'hui un parcours du
combattant.
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là?
Emmanuel Macron, comme ses
prédécesseurs, démolit nos
services publics et nos acquis
sociaux.
Vous condamnez les plus âgés à
travailler 2 ans de plus et
aujourd'hui, lors de la 14e
journée d'une manifestation
historique, les salariés vous
redisent non.
Vous privez la jeunesse à
poursuivre des études supérieures
avec Parcoursup, qui génère du
stress et des angoisses pour les
élèves, les parents et les
enseignants.
Les lycéens ont eu accès à leurs
premiers résultats.
Pour ceux qui ont obtenu la
formation de leur choix, c'est la
fin des incertitudes.
Les autres devront attendre
plusieurs mois avant une réponse
définitive et l'angoisse
s'intensifie.
Certains renoncent à trouver une
place dans le public et
s'inscrivent dans des formations
privées à la qualité parfois
douteuse.
L'an dernier, plus de 100.000
jeunes sont restés sur le carreau
à l'issue de Parcoursup.
Ce sont souvent les élèves issus
des milieux les moins favorisés
qui font les frais de cette
sélection.
On casse le service public et on
favorise des écoles privées, dont
les effectifs ont augmenté de 10%
en un an.
C'est un contresens historique.
Il faut de la qualification dans
tous les domaines pour faire face
aux enjeux sociaux et économiques.
Le savoir est indispensable à
l'émancipation.
Il serait plus efficace de
refonder un vrai service public de
l'orientation et de redonner des
moyens à l'université pour
accueillir tous les étudiants.
La seule façon de rassurer
vraiment notre jeunesse est de
garantir une place pour chaque
bachelier dans le domaine de son
choix et des conditions dignes
pour poursuivre les études.
Quand l'université va-t-elle
bénéficier de la grande loi dont
elle a tant besoin?
Il faut une garantie d'autonomie,
des repas gratuits, des logements
pour les étudiants, recruter des
enseignants: qu'attendez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci à vous.
La parole est à madame Sylvie
Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci.
Monsieur le député Hendrik Davi,
vous avez fait le choix de ne voir
que des défauts dans Parcoursup et
aucune amélioration.
C'est faire bien peu de cas des
travers du passé, que je vais
rappeler.
L'entre-choix, l'autocensure
aggravée par la hiérarchie, la
course à l'inscription...
Votre question est l'occasion de
montrer que nous avons fait
évoluer Parcoursup sur la
transparence, sur l'accompagnement
humain, mais aussi sur
l'efficacité.
Car pour nous, il s'agit de mieux
conseiller et aussi de rassurer.
Oui, il faut de la transparence.
C'est le message que je passe aux
enseignants et responsables du
supérieur, qui ont toute ma
confiance.
On est loin des soupçons
permanents de discrimination que
vous faites peser sur eux.
Là où il n'y avait rien, nous
avons rendu obligatoire
l'affichage des critères.
Cette année, nous avons refondu
leur présentation.
Je m'étais engagée à ce que la
phase d'admission soit plus courte
pour réduire l'attente et le
stress des lycéens et de leurs
familles.
La phase principale est passée à
35 jours, contre 108 en 2018.
Il y avait ce matin plus des trois
quarts des lycéens qui ont reçu
une proposition.
C'est 10 points de plus que l'an
dernier.
Je voudrais finir par vous dire
qu'à côté de votre posture de
dénigrement systématique, à côté
des soupçons de pratiques
discriminantes que vous faites
peser sur les enseignants qui font
partie des commissions des voeux,
nous travaillons à améliorer les
pratiques de Parcoursup pour
réduire le stress des élèves et
des parents plutôt que de faire
des discours.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Frédéric
Falcon.
- Frédéric Falcon: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, chers collègues.
Je veux dénoncer la méthode qui
consiste à interpeller une
présidente de groupe qui ne peut
répondre à des attaques indignes
et honteuses.
Monsieur Sitzenstuhl, vous n'avez
même pas lu ce rapport.
Vous êtes une honte.
La France est enfoncée dans une
crise du logement.
L'offre de logements est
insuffisante pour répondre à la
demande des Français.
Cette crise du logement n'est pas
conjoncturelle, mais elle est le
résultat de l'absence d'une
politique du logement ambitieuse.
Depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron, les taux d'intérêt ont été
relevés et les pénuries de
matières premières ne sont pas
endiguées.
La première cause est la
multiplication des normes.
L'application sans discernement du
zéro
artificialisation nette se fait
que les livraisons attendues pour
l'année 2024 sont bien moindres
que celles qu'il faudrait.
Vous vous attaquez au parc des
logements anciens en interdisant
l'allocation des
passoires thermiques.
Vous organisez à grands coups de
normes énergétiques l'effondrement
de l'offre locative.
Les petits propriétaires voient
leurs biens dépréciés.
N'est-ce pas là l'objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron, qui ne cesse
d'attaquer la propriété
immobilière non délocalisable?
Depuis 2017, vous avez supprimé
l'APL accession, réduit les
dotations et vous vous apprêtez à
supprimer la loi Pinel.
Allez-vous revenir sur les normes
intenables que vous imposez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Frédéric
Falcon, d'une certaine manière,
nous ne sommes jamais déçus sur
votre capacité à exploiter une
crise.
La crise du logement est réelle et
vos réponses sont insuffisantes.
L'objectif du gouvernement est
bien sûr de loger tous les
Français, quel que soit l'état de
leur compte en banque.
C'est de sortir un certain nombre
de nos compatriotes de passoires
thermiques dans lesquelles il est
insupportable de vivre.
Le gouvernement précédent a mis en
place MaPrimeRénov'.
C'est un succès et 1,5 million de
chantiers ont été réalisés depuis
2020.
Jamais autant de chantiers de
rénovation n'ont été mis en oeuvre
dans l'histoire de ce pays.
Ce dispositif est un succès, car
il permet aux propriétaires,
qu'ils soient bailleurs ou
occupants, d'avoir les mêmes aides
pour rénover leur logement.
Au contraire, nous les aidons.
Evidemment, nous sommes attentifs
à tous les pièges.
Un piège serait qu'un certain
nombre de logements passoires
thermiques puissent basculer dans
le meublé touristique.
Nous nous donnons les moyens
d'interdire qu'un meublé
touristique puisse être loué alors
que c'est une passoire thermique.
C'est une priorité du
gouvernement.
Chacun pourra savoir ce qu'il doit
faire dans son logement pour qu'il
mette en oeuvre les travaux de
rénovation afin de sortir des
passoires thermiques.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Marion.
- Christophe Marion: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre déléguée chargée des PME,
du commerce et de l'artisanat.
Avec plus d'1,8 million
d'entreprises et plus de 3
millions d'actifs, le secteur de
l'artisanat joue un rôle clé dans
le secteur économique français.
Nos artisans ont été frappés par
les crises successives.
Il y a eu plusieurs dispositifs
d'aide, comme le bouclier
tarifaire, la stratégie nationale
en faveur des métiers d'art, le
soutient à l'apprentissage et la
réforme des lycées professionnels.
Citons enfin la mobilisation
exemplaire des conseillers à la
sortie de crise dans les
directions départementales des
finances publiques.
Les artisans ont su faire réagir
leur mode de production, adapter
leurs horaires de travail et
proposer de nouveaux services.
Malgré ces actions, la première
entreprise de France reste
fragile.
Dans ma circonscription du
Loir-et-Cher, les boulangers sont
toujours menacés par les pénalités
de rupture.
De nombreux professionnels
subissent aussi la concurrence
déloyale de plates-formes qui
bénéficient d'une forte mise en
valeur de la part des grandes
enseignes et qui proposent de
mettre en relation des
particuliers pour diverses
prestations.
Absence de garantie décennale,
informations mensongères,
prestations payées en liquide qui
échappent à toute la fiscalité,
les dérapages sont nombreux.
Si les artisans s'intéressent à
l'actionnariat salarié, force est
de constater que les dispositifs
actuels, dont sont souvent exclus
les SARL, sont peu adaptés à leurs
besoins.
Que comptez-vous mettre en place
pour limiter la concurrence
déloyale et pour apporter plus de
souplesse à ceux qui souhaitent
innover dans la gestion de leur
entreprise?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Quand vous faites travailler un
artisan, vous achetez plus qu'un
service, vous achetez des
centaines d'heures d'échecs et
d'expérimentations, vous achetez
des jours et des mois de
frustrations et aussi des moments
de joie.
Vous n'achetez pas quelque chose,
vous achetez un morceau de coeur,
une part de quelqu'un.
Ce texte est emprunté à un artisan
de la rue piétonne principale de
Saint-Jean-Pied-de-Port.
Il est utile pour le sens du
lancement de la semaine nationale
de l'artisanat.
Je profite de votre question pour
remercier la présidente du
Parlement, qui a inauguré ce matin
la semaine des métiers de
l'artisanat ici même à
l'Assemblée.
Nous avons ici des artisans et des
apprentis.
Le président de la chambre des
métiers et de l'artisanat est en
tribune.
Nous pouvons le saluer.
Nous pouvons saluer aussi nos
artisans, nos apprentis, nos
forces vives.
Chers députés, les difficultés ont
effectivement été nombreuses cet
hiver.
Nous avons collectivement réussi à
mettre en place des aides, mais
surtout à informer.
31.000 boulangers ont été appelés
directement par les chambres de
métiers de l'artisanat.
Nous restons attentifs à leur
situation.
Nous avons été présents.
Nous continuerons à être présents.
Vous avez aussi mentionné des
pratiques de mises en relation
directe sur les plates-formes.
Nous sommes vigilants, avec la
direction générale de la
consommation, de la concurrence et
de la répression des fraudes.
J'ai lancé une application qui a
été téléchargée pas loin de
100.000 fois.
Je suggère à nos compatriotes
victimes d'arnaques de les
déclarer directement ligne pour
que nous puissions effectuer des
contrôles et sanctionner ces
pratiques abusives.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Alexandra
Martin.
- Alexandra Martin: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Education nationale, le suicide
de Lindsay a ému la France entière
et a démontré une fois de plus
l'échec de votre politique de
prévention.
Nous pensons à cet instant à
Lindsay et aux victimes
harcèlement scolaire.
C'est un des nombreux symptômes
d'une violence sociale
grandissante, notamment chez les
plus jeunes.
Elle doit être partout combattue
avec force.
En dépit de la loi, la tendance ne
faiblit pas.
Dans chaque classe, trois élèves y
sont confrontés.
Les répercussions sont colossales.
Echec scolaire, déscolarisation et
souvent pensées suicidaires.
Les harcèlements sont pourtant
souvent connus.
Les familles se sentent
désespérément seules, comme depuis
le début de leurs alertes.
Le programme de prévention pHARe
est impuissant.
Absent de nombreux établissements,
vous ne reconnaissez pas à de
nombreux élèves le droit d'étudier
dans un environnement protégé et
de vivre en sécurité.
Qui aurait dû les protéger?
D'abord la puissance publique.
Quand allez-vous responsabiliser
les auteurs et leurs parents,
comme je l'appelle de mes voeux,
en matière de délinquance des
mineurs?
Vous avez annoncé que la mesure
d'éloignement des harceleurs était
une solution de dernier recours.
La victime subit alors une double
peine.
Responsabiliser, c'est faire
prendre conscience au harceleur de
son délit.
C'est à lui qu'il revient de
quitter l'établissement, pas à la
victime.
Quant à la communauté éducative,
quand sera-t-elle formée pour ne
plus considérer le harcèlement
scolaire comme une affaire
d'enfants?
Quand allez-vous sommer les
réseaux sociaux d'agir?
Quand allez-vous prendre des
mesures pour garantir le droit à
étudier en toute sérénité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Madame la députée Alexandra
Martin, vous avez raison de
souligner que le harcèlement est
un drame.
C'est un drame pour notre école,
pour notre pays, et nous devons
nous mobiliser pour cela.
C'est ce que le ministère de
l'Education nationale fait depuis
2019, d'abord de manière
expérimentale dans six académies.
Le programme auquel vous faites
allusion a été étendu à l'ensemble
des académies pour les écoles et
les collèges à la rentrée 2022 et
le sera pour les lycées à la
rentrée 2023.
La situation est-elle
satisfaisante?
Le programme s'est-il déployé
partout de manière homogène?
La réponse est non.
Nous avons du chemin à faire.
Je veux bien vous le dire une
nouvelle fois: c'est un travail
patient.
C'est un travail qui demande de la
mobilisation, des moyens, et nous
faisons des questions de
harcèlement une priorité.
D'abord par les enquêtes
administratives qui sont
diligentées par l'inspection
générale.
Des sanctions seront prises s'il y
a lieu.
Un certain nombre d'enquêtes sont
en cours.
Ensuite, nous étendons les
programmes de détection et de
prise en charge.
Cela veut dire que nous formons
des personnels.
Il y a aussi des moyens
supplémentaires pour les numéros
d'appel qui recueillent une grande
audience.
Un référent rémunéré sera dans
chaque collège à partir de la
rentrée pour ne s'occuper que des
questions de harcèlement.
Les dépôts de plaintes seront
systématisés dès que la nouvelle
d'un harcèlement avéré ou suspect
sera faite.
L'éloignement du harceleur fait
l'objet d'un décret qui est
actuellement au Conseil d'Etat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin.
- Marie-Charlotte Garin: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur, vous vous trompez de
cible.
Nous allons vivre un été infernal.
Tous les voyants sont au rouge.
Sécheresse hivernale, nappes
phréatiques au plus bas, feux de
forêt précoces, et pendant ce
temps, vous faites des GPS
espions, des marquages sur la
peau.
Il n'y a pas d'argent magique,
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y en a quand
il s'agit de réprimer les
militants!
Vous mettez au service d'intérêts
privés un arsenal policier et
judiciaire sans précédent.
Vous gaspillez de l'argent public
pour protéger une poignée de
privilégiés.
Votre offensive contre les
militants qui défendent notre bien
commun est inédite.
Avec vous, sans surprise, c'est
toujours la même devise: dur avec
les gens, faible avec les
puissants.
Vous ne jouez pas avec le feu,
vous démarrez les incendies.
Vous vous déchaînez contre nous
parce que vous avez peur.
Vous avez peur parce que nous
sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous soulever.
Nous ne sommes pas que de méchants
radicaux, comme vous le
pensez.
Nous sommes infirmières,
scientifiques, ouvriers,
étudiants, philosophes,
agriculteurs, artistes...
Vous avez peur de nous, les
raisonnables, les défenseurs du
vivant.
Comme d'habitude, vous allez jouer
de la caricature, flirter avec le
mensonge.
Nous serions les violents, les
irresponsables, mais la vérité,
c'est que les militants que vous
arrêtez ont le courage que vous
n'avez pas.
Quand allez-vous faire preuve de
courage?
Quand allez-vous changer de cible?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée, je n'ai pas
bien compris l'objet de votre
question.
Je crois que vous étiez partie
pour m'interroger sur les
interpellations des personnes qui
ont saccagé l'usine Lafarge.
Vous avez dû constater que c'est
sous l'autorité de magistrats
indépendants que les policiers ont
opéré ces interpellations.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Marie-Charlotte Garin: On
comprend qui vous protégez et qui
a vos faveurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je propose que l'on évite les
procès d'intention.
Parlez clairement, vous le devez à
vos électeurs.
Pardon de ne pas comprendre que,
lorsque vous avez dans un pays des
magistrats indépendants qui
ouvrent des enquêtes, soit parce
que l'on a attenté à la vie des
gendarmes comme Sainte-Soline, et
vous n'avez eu aucun mot de
compassion pour ces nombreux
blessés...
Applaudissements
Soit parce que l'on saccage des
musées, alors que l'on ne voit pas
bien le lien avec la défense de
l'écologie, soit parce que l'on
fait des atteintes aux biens...
Vous n'avez pas la majorité morale
et politique pour imposer vos
idées à la République française.
Madame la députée, il faut
accepter que vous n'avez pas de
supériorité morale, pas plus que
n'importe quel autre citoyen.
Les policiers et les gendarmes ne
font qu'appliquer les lois que
nous votons et que vous votez ici,
les lois voulues par le peuple
français et qu'il n'y a pas le
camp du bien et les autres.
Il n'y a que la République
française, que des magistrats
indépendants et des policiers et
gendarmes qui font leur travail,
ne vous en déplaise.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Perrine
Goulet.
- Perrine Goulet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat chargée de
l'enfance.
Le comité des droits de l'enfant
des Nations Unies vient de rendre
ses observations sur l'application
de la Convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant par la
France.
Il me sera impossible de balayer
ici l'ensemble du rapport, mais la
délégation aura l'opportunité de
vous entendre à la fin du mois.
Les politiques de la protection
des enfants connaissent un regain
d'activité et d'intérêts et ont
une place à part dans l'action
publique.
Les Nations Unies le reconnaissent
et le saluent.
Plusieurs plans ont été mis en
oeuvre par ce gouvernement et le
précédent en faveur de la
protection des enfants.
Le comité salue leur existence et
leur légitimité.
Leur efficacité s'apprécie
fortement après une réévaluation
nécessaire.
Le gouvernement et le parlement
devront s'atteler à cela.
Si je ne devais retenir qu'un axe
de ce rapport, ce serait celui
d'une meilleure connaissance par
les enfants de leurs droits.
Le droit qu'ils ont à aller à
l'école, le droit à des soins, le
droit à la sécurité, le droit de
ne pas se faire harceler en ligne
ou dans la rue, le droit à
l'intimité, le droit à son
intégrité, le droit d'être défendu
et d'obtenir justice, le droit de
ne pas être violenté, le droit
d'être un enfant et juste un
enfant.
Si tous les enfants avaient
connaissance de leurs droits, ils
obligeraient les adultes à les
respecter.
Nous pouvons être satisfaits
collectivement des conclusions de
ce rapport, mais si dans cette
matière, il faut toujours remettre
l'ouvrage sur ce métier, je suis
convaincue que nos efforts
collectifs nous permettront encore
de progresser et ce rapport nous
montre le chemin.
Pouvez-vous nous préciser quelles
sont les prochaines actions que
vous allez mener avec le
gouvernement en faveur des enfants
et en matière d'appropriation par
les enfants de leurs droits?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Le gouvernement français était
très attendu par cette évaluation
du respect des droits des enfants
devant le comité de l'ONU.
N'en déplaise à tous ceux qui ont
critiqué la France, le rapport est
plutôt laudatif et, notamment sur
les qualités de la préparation,
mais surtout sur la qualité de
l'action des gouvernements depuis
2017.
Le rapport souligne la création
d'un secrétariat d'Etat dédié à la
protection des enfants, mais aussi
à la création de votre délégation
et l'implication des pouvoirs
publics pour faire respecter les
droits des enfants.
L'ensemble des avancées
législatives sont saluées, et
elles sont nombreuses.
La stratégie de lutte contre les
violences faites aux enfants a été
saluée, j'en ferai un bilan
demain en Conseil des ministres.
Je donnerai des perspectives,
puisqu'il reste beaucoup de choses
à faire, comme en témoigne la
triste histoire de Lindsay.
Nous devons mieux faire pour nos
enfants et ce rapport sera au
coeur du comité interministériel
de l'enfance que je tiendrai le 15
juin au nom de la Première
ministre.
Nous avons bien sûr le sujet des
enfants en situation de handicap,
celle des enfants en situation de
pauvreté, des enfants migrants,
des enfants ultramarins...
Tous ces sujets sont au coeur des
priorités du gouvernement.
Nous nous y attellerons.
Il y a la question de la
connaissance des droits par les
enfants.
Nous poussons un passeport
d'éducation aux droits, il est
très important.
Nous poussons les jeunes
ambassadeurs des droits des
enfants.
Le parlement des enfants sera
réuni dans quelques semaines et
nous serons là pour répondre aux
questions des enfants.
Nous sommes donc au rendez-vous
des droits des enfants.
Le rapport du comité nous oblige.
Nous continuons à nous atteler.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Vincent
Descoeur.
- Vincent Descoeur: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
en charge des Solidarités.
Les EHPAD sont confrontés à des
difficultés de fonctionnement qui
les fragilisent et font peser une
menace sur leur avenir, des
difficultés d'ordre budgétaire en
raison d'un contexte d'inflation
qui se traduit par une hausse de
leurs charges fixes, notamment des
denrées alimentaires et de
l'énergie, des dépenses
d'hébergement qui ont progressé
bien plus vite que les tarifs
d'hébergement.
Cela a pour effet de placer ces
établissements, nos maisons de
retraite, dans une situation d'une
gravité inédite.
En début d'année, la Fédération
hospitalière de France révélait
que 39% des EHPAD publics
rencontraient des difficultés de
trésorerie et que 85% d'entre eux
anticipaient un résultat fortement
déficitaire à la fin de l'exercice
2022.
Fragilisés par la crise sanitaire,
cela a mis leur personnel à rude
épreuve.
Nos EHPAD doivent en outre faire
face à des difficultés de
recrutement qui les contraignent à
recourir à l'intérim, dont le coût
excessif grève encore plus encore
leur budget.
Il y a urgence à agir, si on veut
éviter la multiplication des
fermetures de lits, ou pire
encore, de certains établissements
qui risquent de se retrouver sous
peu en cessation de paiements.
Ces établissements ne peuvent pas
attendre plusieurs mois encore la
grande réforme du grand âge
régulièrement annoncée et sans
cesse reportée.
Aussi, je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez nous indiquer quelles
mesures comptent mettre en oeuvre
les membres du gouvernement pour
aider les EHPAD à surmonter cette
crise sans précédent, rassurer
leurs gestionnaires, leur
personnel, les aînés et leurs
familles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Monsieur
le député Descoeur, vous faites
état d'une situation dégradée de
nos établissements pour les
personnes âgées depuis quelques
mois.
La réalité, c'est que l'Etat
soutient massivement les EHPAD
depuis plusieurs années
maintenant.
Je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'ensemble des crédits qui ont été
délégués pendant la crise
sanitaire, la compensation des
augmentations liées au Ségur de la
santé, l'augmentation des
effectifs d'infirmières de nuit,
l'augmentation des temps de
médecins coordinateurs dans ces
établissements.
Il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui, dans
une période d'inflation, la
situation est toujours difficile.
Vous avez cité les tensions sur
les recrutements.
Il y a un taux d'occupation qui
est très bas dans nos EHPAD.
Contre cela, nous avons choisi des
mesures beaucoup plus ciblées.
On a délégué 440 millions d'euros
pour soutenir le financement des
EHPAD, dont 100 millions juste
pour l'inflation.
On a étendu le bouclier tarifaire
sur le gaz et l'électricité à
l'ensemble de ces établissements.
On a augmenté les financements des
EHPAD de 5,1%.
J'ai demandé à l'ensemble des
directeurs généraux des ARS de
suivre la situation des EHPAD qui
sont en difficulté.
On ne laissera aucun EHPAD en
difficulté ou aucun EHPAD
contraint de fermer.
On a doublé, voire triplé sur
certains territoires, les crédits
reconductibles.
Pour autant, on voit bien que les
difficultés subsistent, notamment
celles liées à la section
hébergement de ces établissements,
section qui dépend des
financements des départements.
Je suis en lien constant avec les
départements pour trouver des
solutions et permettre aux
établissements d'être mieux
financés.
J'ai saisi l'ensemble de mes
administrations pour mettre en
place un groupe de travail sur
l'évolution, avec les
départements, pour travailler sur
l'évolution du modèle économique
des EHPAD.
Seule une réponse structurelle
permettra d'apporter des
financements nécessaires et de
maintenir l'accessibilité de
l'offre.
On sait qu'on a un
sous-financement, aujourd'hui, de
l'aide sociale à l'hébergement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Descoeur?
- Vincent Descoeur: Je suis au
regret de vous dire que votre
réponse n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux.
L'enjeu, c'est l'attention que
l'on doit porter à nos aînés.
C'est la reconnaissance que l'on
doit au personnel qui les entoure.
La question de la solidarité entre
les générations, c'est un devoir
et non une option.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Thierry Benoit.
- Thierry Benoit: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Industrie, je
souhaite aborder aujourd'hui la
décision du groupe Le Duff de
renoncer à la construction d'une
nouvelle usine, fabrication de
viennoiseries en Bretagne.
Le directeur fait le choix
d'investir 250 millions d'euros
dans notre pays et ainsi créer 500
emplois directs, ce qui induit la
création de 1500 emplois
indirects.
Le gouvernement français souhaite
réindustrialiser la France.
Comment passer de la parole aux
actes?
Ce cas d'école pose aux décideurs
les problématiques du moment:
artificialisation des sols,
consommation de l'eau, pratiques
durables liées à l'import-export.
Est-il acceptable de laisser le
groupe Le Duff partir investir
ailleurs dans l'Union Européenne,
alors que nous sommes soumis aux
mêmes enjeux de transition
écologique et d'économie
décarbonée dans tous les
Etats-membres de l'Union
Européenne?
Enfin, la persistance des recours
et des contentieux à perpétuité
voulus par quelques activistes
peuvent-ils avoir raison de
l'initiative entrepreneuriale et
de la volonté politique de
concilier économie et écologie,
alors que toutes les procédures
ont été respectées et les
autorisations administratives
accordées?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Monsieur le
député Thierry Benoit, merci pour
votre question et merci aussi pour
votre implication dans ce dossier,
qui est important dans votre
département, même si je sais qu'il
n'est pas spécifique à votre
circonscription.
Le dossier auquel vous faites
référence, la nouvelle usine,
était un dossier complexe au
niveau environnemental, avec de la
zone humide, 36 espèces protégées,
des enjeux de réutilisation d'eau.
Tous ces obstacles ont été levés,
en grande partie grâce aux efforts
de l'industriel, qui a accepté de
baisser sa consommation d'eau dans
le cadre de son projet, mais aussi
des services de l'Etat.
On a réussi à obtenir une
autorisation.
Suite à cette autorisation en
juillet 2022, un certain nombre de
recours ont été déposés.
Ces recours sont non suspensifs.
L'un d'entre eux a déjà été
rejeté.
Il en reste quatre.
Suite à ces recours, le groupe Le
Duff a décidé d'abandonner ce
projet et de l'installer ailleurs.
C'est une décision que je
regrette.
Nous avons échangé avec les
équipes.
Je n'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec lui.
J'essaierai de tirer toutes les
leçons de cette expérience.
L'Ille-et-Vilaine et la France
sont grandes.
Nous allons examiner avec lui
d'autres projets potentiels.
Je tiens à mentionner que le sujet
confirme la règle de la
réindustrialisation de la France.
Ce projet a été abandonné, mais
nous avons d'autres projets qui
ont été confirmés par Bruno Le
Maire.
Nous devons réindustrialiser la
France de manière plus efficace.
Je vous invite à regarder ce sujet
très important des recours pour
voir si nous pouvons améliorer les
procédures, de manière à faire
encore mieux.
- Thierry Benoit: Je remercie le
ministre pour sa réponse.
Je souhaite de tout coeur que le
gouvernement, avec les services de
l'Etat, les acteurs du territoire,
puisse retisser les liens avec nos
entrepreneurs, et notamment avec
Louis Le Duff.
Il n'y a pas de raison qu'en
France, on ne réussisse pas ce
pari de la réindustrialisation.
Nous avons encore plus de
responsabilités lorsqu'il s'agit
de groupes familiaux et
d'entrepreneurs français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Mélanie
Thomin.
- Mélanie Thomin: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, il y
a un peu plus d'un an, vous étiez
nommée Première ministre avec ce
souhait du président de la
République: agir sans relâche pour
les Françaises et les Français,
pour entre autres la santé et la
renaissance démocratique.
Où en êtes-vous de cette promesse
sur la santé?
On se prépare encore une fois à
compter nos morts dans nos
hôpitaux, où manquent les
soignants et ferment les services
d'urgence.
Où en êtes-vous de cette promesse
sur la santé quand les maternités
des territoires ruraux comme à
Carhaix, Landerneau, Guingamp
menacent de fermer faute
d'anesthésiste?
La crainte d'un démantèlement par
service est réelle.
A Carhaix, presque un tiers des
lits est fermé sans garantie de
rouvrir.
Quand il n'y a pas d'alternative,
pas de médecine de nuit
suffisante, toute suspension ou
fermeture partielle est une
atteinte potentielle à la vie
d'autrui.
Une atteinte grave au pacte
républicain, notre santé et nos
hôpitaux brûlent.
C'est un renoncement terrible.
Les citoyens ont le sentiment
d'être abandonnés dans une
stratégie de pourrissement.
Où en êtes-vous de cette promesse
de renouveau démocratique quand
votre majorité relative n'a qu'à
l'esprit d'éviter un vote sur la
réforme des retraites, en
confondant créativité
constitutionnelle et mise en
danger des droits du Parlement?
Où en êtes-vous de cette
renaissance démocratique quand vos
budgets ne sont adoptés que par
49.3 et que, hier soir encore,
chaque loi de règlement est
rejetée par notre Assemblée?
Dans le monde réel, celui des
collectivités, des associations,
des entreprises, quand une
Assemblée vote contre le quitus
financier, l'exécutif démissionne.
Vous n'avez eu de cesse d'agir
sans relâche contre les Françaises
et les Français.
Qu'en est-il de cette promesse que
le président de la République
faisait à votre égard?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Madame la
députée, je vais tâcher de
répondre à votre question, qui
touche à des secteurs que je
connais bien.
Vous interrogez la méthode.
Je crois aussi aux chiffres.
La plupart des textes qui ont été
présentés par la Première ministre
et son gouvernement depuis un an
ont été adoptés par le Parlement.
Vous-même, vous avez eu l'occasion
de voter favorablement sur un
certain nombre de projets de loi,
et c'est tant mieux.
Les Français ne pourraient pas
concevoir que l'on tomberait
d'accord sur tous les textes.
Néanmoins, il y a quelques textes
sur lesquels on peut avoir des
désaccords, notamment le texte sur
les retraites.
D'autres textes ont été adoptés
avec les voix de la gauche sans la
droite, et inversement.
C'est le souhait des Français, qui
nous ont confié une majorité
relative, que de nous demander
pour la première fois depuis des
années de chercher
systématiquement le désaccord avec
la gauche et la droite pour faire
avancer le pays.
Ce que l'on peut déplorer
ensemble, c'est peut-être les
outrances, les excès, les postures
qui grèvent parfois les débats au
Parlement et ailleurs.
Mais je peux vous dire que je vais
à la rencontre des Français et des
Françaises comme vous, madame la
députée, et qu'ils attendent du
Parlement que ce soit un endroit
où on est capable d'échanger et de
se dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord
mais qu'on peut aussi l'être
parfois.
Avoir systématiquement des députés
qui hurlent par-dessus un ministre
pour couvrir sa voix, ce n'est pas
un exemple très démocratique.
On doit être capable de commencer
à revoir un peu les méthodes et
les dysfonctionnements pour se
dire que ce dont les Français ont
besoin, c'est de l'apaisement.
Quand il s'agit ensuite des
priorités, vous avez cité la
santé.
On pourrait citer l'éducation.
Dès que je parle, vous hurlez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous n'avez
pas la parole!
- Olivier Véran: Nous avançons
dans une direction qui est celle
que nous ont confiée les Français.
Il n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne
soit pas capables de tomber
d'accord sur beaucoup de ces
textes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je donne la parole à monsieur
Jean-René Cazeneuve.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Au préalable, je voudrais revenir
sur le rejet, hier, des projets de
loi de règlement 2021 et 2022,
parce que, une fois de plus, le
Rassemblement National et la NUPES
ont voté ensemble contre un arrêté
comptable, contre un document
budgétaire nécessaire pour
l'administration et pour nos
fonctionnaires.
Ils ont voté ensemble contre les
intérêts de notre pays.
Ici, il y a ceux qui sont contre
tout et ceux qui sont au travail
pour l'intérêt de nos concitoyens.
Monsieur le ministre, je voudrais
revenir sur la décision de
maintenir l'index de la dette
française.
C'est un signal positif pour notre
pays.
Elle conforte notre stratégie de
réforme afin d'atteindre le
plein-emploi.
Elle conforte les choix
économiques que nous avons faits
depuis 2017.
Elle conforte enfin la trajectoire
de maîtrise des finances publiques
que nous nous sommes fixée.
Mais cette notation nous engage.
Elle nous engage car oui, nous
devons absolument assurer la bonne
exécution de cette trajectoire.
Oui, nous devons absolument
accélérer le désendettement de la
France, dont on sait qu'il est un
poison pour les générations
futures.
Oui, nous devons ramener le
déficit en dessous des 3% d'ici 4
ans.
Oui, nous devons maîtriser la
croissance de nos dépenses
publiques dès le prochain budget.
Il en va de notre crédibilité.
Il en va de notre capacité à
investir massivement, en
particulier sur la transition
écologique.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler votre
stratégie pour tenir notre
trajectoire de maîtrise de la
dépense publique?
Pouvez-vous nous assurer que les
propositions concrètes de
réduction des dépenses seront
faites dès le prochain PLF?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le rapporteur
général.
La parole est à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
rapporteur général, comme vous
l'avez dit, l'agence de notation
Standard & Poor's a décidé de
maintenir la note de la France
inchangée, ce qui est un signal
positif, la reconnaissance du
travail que vous avez engagé
personnellement et que toute cette
majorité a engagé pour rétablir
les finances publiques et la
reconnaissance de la crédibilité
du travail qui a été faite depuis
2017, quand nous sommes sortis de
la procédure et revenus sous les
3% de déficit.
Avec Elisabeth Borne, avec le
président de la République, nous
sommes totalement déterminés à
tenir notre trajectoire de finance
publique avec fermeté et dans la
clarté la plus totale.
Cela suppose d'abord de continuer
à avoir une croissance positive.
Certains de nos voisins affichent
désormais de la récession, et
nous, nous avons de la croissance.
Nous continuons à créer des
emplois et nous ouvrons des usines
dans notre pays.
C'est le résultat de notre
politique économique.
Le deuxième pilier de notre
stratégie, c'est de sortir
définitivement du "quoi qu'il en
coûte", qui était nécessaire pour
protéger nos entreprises et
salariés face à l'inflation et la
crise du Covid mais qui,
aujourd'hui, serait totalement
inapproprié.
Nous sortirons du "quoi qu'il en
coûte".
Nous mettrons fin progressivement
au bouclier énergétique et aux
chèques exceptionnels.
Le troisième pilier de cette
stratégie que nous avons définie
avec la Première ministre, c'est
d'engager nos revues de dépenses
publiques sur chacun des secteurs
de dépenses publiques pour
s'assurer que l'argent public est
bien employé et que chaque euro
d'argent public, qui est un euro
du contribuable gagné par le
travail du contribuable, est utile
pour nos services publics, pour
nos compatriotes.
C'est comme cela que nous
tiendrons nos objectifs et que
nous serons sous les 3% de déficit
en 2027 et que nous allons
accélérer le désendettement du
pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Thibaut François.
- Thibaut François: Mes chers
collègues, ma question s'adresse à
monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
Le savoir est de beaucoup la
portion la plus considérable du
bonheur, c'est ce que disait
Sophocle.
Tragique, c'est la situation des
personnes porteuses de handicap
dans la France entière sous votre
gouvernement.
Ils sont plus de 8000 porteurs de
handicap intellectuel dans le
département du Nord à ne pas
bénéficier d'une prise en charge
adaptée.
Tragique, c'est la lettre de mise
en demeure reçue par des parents
pour non-scolarisation de leurs
enfants, alors que les parents ont
du mal à trouver des
établissements adaptés pour leurs
enfants.
Notre système d'éducation laisse
sur le côté ces enfants sans
instruction et les parents dans un
état de détresse incommensurable.
Les enfants sont regroupés dans
des salles communes sans éveil
particulier, sans programme
éducatif adapté, malgré tout le
dévouement du personnel soignant.
Vous êtes coupables de ne pas
respecter notre Constitution qui
garantit l'égalité dans
l'éducation pour tous et à tous
les degrés.
Oui, pour tous.
Ma question est simple:
comptez-vous faire quelque chose
pour appliquer le principe
d'égalité, qui est un principe
constitutionnel, et permettre à
ces enfants de bénéficier d'une
éducation adaptée à leur handicap
et donc d'accéder au savoir, à la
découverte, à l'éveil et donc au
bonheur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Monsieur le député
Thibaut François, cette question,
je me pencherai sur le cas
spécifique que vous venez
d'indiquer, mais je voudrais
d'abord faire une remarque
générale.
C'est celle des plus de 430.000
enfants en situation de handicap
que l'école scolarise aujourd'hui.
C'est 3 fois plus qu'en 2005,
lorsque la loi a été votée.
Nous avons, et je l'ai moi-même
reconnu devant vous, mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires, un
certain nombre de difficultés
aujourd'hui dans l'école
inclusive, des difficultés
auxquelles la Conférence nationale
sur le handicap, qui s'est tenue
notamment dans sa fonction
conclusive le 26 avril dernier,
essaie de répondre.
Voilà les mesures que nous mettons
en place avec la ministre
Geneviève Darrieussecq.
Tout d'abord, tous les enfants en
situation de handicap
bénéficieront d'un numéro national
d'identification à la rentrée.
C'était une demande des familles
et des associations depuis
longtemps.
Ensuite, nous améliorons la
situation des AESH.
Nous aurons une augmentation de
10% de ses agents.
Il y a également un rapprochement
avec la vie scolaire pour tendre
vers les 35 heures.
Nous faisons également en amont
une instance de discussion avec la
famille sur la scolarisation des
enfants.
Cela concerne aussi les enfants
qui souffrent de handicap
intellectuel, ce à quoi vous
faites allusion dans votre
circonscription.
Je vais me pencher sur ce cas que
je ne connais pas précisément et
je vous apporterai une réponse
circonstanciée.
Quoi qu'il en soit, notre
détermination est entière pour la
scolarisation de ces enfants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Thibaut François: Monsieur le
ministre, je suis désolé, mais je
crois que votre réponse est loin
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux.
Vous dites que vous ne connaissez
pas la situation de ma
circonscription.
Je viens de vous citer plus de
8000 personnes porteuses de
handicap qui sont dans le
département du Nord.
Je vais sûrement vous annoncer
quelque chose: vous êtes
probablement au courant qu'en
Belgique, beaucoup
d'établissements sont en train de
fermer en ce moment même, donc
tous les reports sont en train de
se faire sur le département du
Nord.
Je crains que votre réponse ne
soit pas satisfaisante.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Michel Sala.
- Michel Sala: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture, le 24 mai 2023,
après consultation du comité sur
les ressources en eau, la préfète
du Gard a signé la version
définitive de l'arrêté-cadre
sécheresse.
La moitié du département est en
situation de crise, et
l'irrigation des cultures est
interdite.
Les Pyrénées-Orientales, l'Aude,
les Bouches-du-Rhône et d'autres
départements connaissent des
situations similaires.
Selon le GIEC, cette situation
anormale sera de plus en plus
fréquente, et dans quelques
décennies, elle deviendra la règle
pour la région méditerranéenne.
Anticiper permettra de ne pas être
confronté à des choix très
violents d'ici 10 ou 20 ans.
L'eau est un bien commun en
raréfaction.
L'accaparement de cette ressource
par une minorité via la
construction de méga-bassines
provoque déjà des tensions
insupportables.
Alors, ce n'est pas tout de mettre
en place des arrêtés sécheresse.
Il faut envisager immédiatement
une planification à plus long
terme.
Pour éviter des crises de plus en
plus graves, il n'existe pas de
solution unique pour tout le
territoire.
Les agriculteurs et agricultrices
connaissent leur terroir et savent
ce qu'il y est possible d'y faire.
Il y aura des pertes de production
pour de nombreuses cultures.
Pour l'arboriculture, les plants
sont déjà fragilisés par les
épisodes de sécheresse précédents,
et les conséquences se feront
sentir sur le long terme.
Emmanuel Macron a fait le choix de
favoriser le secteur privé des
assurances plutôt que d'élargir
efficacement le fonds de
solidarité nationale.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2023, les
agriculteurs sont incités à
souscrire une assurance récolte
pour être mieux indemnisés.
Mais certaines compagnies
d'assurances imposent une clause
d'exclusion d'indemnisation en cas
de restriction administrative
d'usage de l'eau.
Les agriculteurs sont pris en
étau.
A cela s'ajoutent des niveaux
d'indemnisation qui ne sont pas à
la hauteur des pertes.
Augmenter le taux de compensation
et le conditionner à l'engagement
dans une démarche d'adaptation des
cultures au changement climatique
serait un début de solution.
Dans mon département, les petites
exploitations représentent 65% des
producteurs.
Elles n'ont pas toujours la
trésorerie pour affronter ces
nouvelles crises.
Entendez-vous la détresse du monde
agricole?
Qu'allez-vous faire pour le
soutenir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député Michel Sala, d'abord, vous
avez cité ce comité ressources en
eau qui s'est tenu le 24 mai, qui
a été l'occasion pour la
préfecture du Gard de valider la
crise sur différents cours d'eau
et, plus largement, de rappeler
les zones qui sont concernées par
l'alerte renforcée et de poser ce
nouvel arrêté de sécheresse.
Au-delà de la dimension locale,
dont on aura à rediscuter très
bientôt, compte tenu des enjeux
particuliers du dérèglement
climatique dans la Camargue, un
rapport est en cours de
finalisation pour voir comment la
salinisation méritait d'être prise
en compte.
Votre question pose la question de
l'adaptation de notre système
assurantiel aux dérèglements
climatiques et à ce que cela
entraîne en termes de
bouleversements.
Dans les mois qui viennent, parmi
les chantiers, il y a la révision
des référentiels techniques, mais
en parallèle, il y a cette
question du rythme de ce qu'on
appelle les catastrophes
naturelles, avec notamment des
difficultés sur les pertes de
récolte.
Cela va nécessiter une refonte de
notre système assuranciel.
On est dans cette planification.
On se bat pour se préparer aux
conséquences d'un réchauffement
qui est déjà là et pour lequel
nous avons à anticiper.
De ce point de vue, il faut du
travail, de la constance, de la
cohérence.
Il faut se garder des formules
toutes faites.
Je vous remercie pour votre
question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Marcellin Nadeau.
- Marcellin Nadeau: Merci.
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux,
ministre de la Justice, vous vous
êtes rendu récemment aux Antilles
et avez pu constater la situation
difficile d'exercice des missions
de justice en Martinique comme en
Guadeloupe.
Bien que préoccupante également
dans l'Hexagone, la situation des
prisons est dramatique dans les
outre-mer.
C'est vrai aux Antilles mais aussi
à La Réunion et à Mayotte.
Je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur les centres
pénitentiaires dans nos régions,
qui ne disposent d'aucune unité
hospitalière de soins.
Des centres pénitentiaires qui ne
disposent pas de prêche pour les
extractions judiciaires.
S'agissant de la prise en charge
médicale des détenus, il n'y a que
cinq chambres sanitaires
carcérales à Fort-de-France.
Nous avons pu constater, lors
d'une visite, leur état d'extrême
indignité.
La Martinique, la Guadeloupe comme
la Guyane et La Réunion ont
pourtant grand besoin de ces
unités sanitaires spécialisées,
car elles sont frappées d'une
double peine: une population
carcérale qui vieillit et qui a
donc besoin de soins plus
réguliers d'une part, une
population carcérale qui,
paradoxalement, rajeunit d'autre
part, avec des pathologies
spécifiques nécessitant un
accompagnement sanitaire et
surtout psychologique.
Magistrats, médecins,
professionnels pénitentiaires sont
unanimes: il faut implanter ces
unités sanitaires en Martinique
comme en Guadeloupe et à La
Réunion.
Ma question est donc celle-ci: à
quand l'implantation de ces
structures afin de résorber cette
trop importante et grave inégalité
structurelle entre l'Hexagone et
l'outre-mer, singulièrement la
Martinique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député Marcellin Nadeau,
j'excuse le garde des
Sceaux parce qu'il est au Sénat en
ce moment même pour consacrer de
nouveaux moyens à notre système de
justice, dans le cadre du projet
de loi dédié.
Vous posez des questions
légitimes.
C'est un sujet que nous prenons
très au sérieux.
Il y a un plan de 15.000 places de
prison qui est actuellement mis en
oeuvre et qui constitue un levier
pérenne de manière à réduire la
surpopulation carcérale et
améliorer de fait les conditions
de détention et de travail pour
les personnels.
J'ajoute que le ministre de la
Justice s'est très récemment rendu
en Martinique.
Vous connaissez toute son
attention pour votre territoire.
Il a posé la première pierre d'une
des 12 structures d'accompagnement
vers la sortie du territoire
national.
Il y a également inauguré le
premier atelier en outre-mer du
service de l'emploi pénitentiaire,
qui permet aux détenus qui le
souhaitent de travailler.
Les services de l'administration
pénitentiaire, avec ceux de
l'hôpital, travaillent à améliorer
concrètement la prise en charge
des détenus.
Huit chambres sécurisées seront
disponibles à l'hôpital pour
assurer une prise en charge
somatique mais aussi psychiatrique
la plus adaptée possible.
Une feuille de route santé et
justice 2023-2028 est en cours de
finalisation, de manière à
améliorer l'ensemble des
dispositifs dédiés à cette prise
en charge sanitaire des détenus.
La sécurité pénitentiaire est une
préoccupation majeure du garde des
Sceaux.
Une équipe spéciale sera déployée
à l'automne prochain sur votre
territoire.
Ce type de démarches se déploie
également sur les autres
territoires ultramarins que vous
avez cités.
L'outre-mer est très présent dans
l'action de nos ministères.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous avez deux
secondes.
- Marcellin Nadeau: Les ministres
font un petit tour et puis s'en
vont, et nos problèmes restent
entiers.
Donnez-nous ces structures, nous
en avons besoin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Michèle Peyron.
- Michèle Peyron: Madame la
présidente, ma question s'adresse
au ministre des Solidarités.
Suite à de nombreuses
concertations, madame la Première
ministre a présenté les premières
mesures du service public de la
petite enfance.
Le gouvernement veut répondre à
une inquiétude légitime des
parents par la création de ce
service public placé sous la
responsabilité des communes.
Nous répondons aux préoccupations
des parents en leur apportant une
solution cohérente avec leurs
besoins.
Nous créons des relais petite
enfance qui leur apporteront les
informations nécessaires.
Le gouvernement sera aux côtés des
communes pour la mise en place du
service public de la petite
enfance, notamment face à la
pénurie des places d'accueil, en
consentant un investissement
massif de 5,5 milliards d'euros
pour atteindre l'ouverture de
100.000 places supplémentaires à
l'horizon 2027, puis 300.000 à
l'horizon 2030.
La garantie de l'accueil de chaque
enfant est un enjeu d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes.
Cet accueil doit être réellement
universel pour répondre aux
besoins de toutes les familles de
tous les jeunes enfants.
Que ce soit des familles
monoparentales, à horaires
atypiques, des familles précaires,
que les enfants soient en
situation de handicap ou non, la
qualité de l'accueil reste une
priorité.
Vous lancez des concertations sur
les référentiels nationaux.
Pouvez-vous revenir plus
précisément sur le contenu des
mesures relatives à l'accueil des
jeunes enfants et sur les
concertations en cours?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre des
Solidarités, de l'Autonomie et des
Personnes handicapées.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Votre question me permet de
revenir sur les annonces faites
par madame la Première ministre
jeudi dernier à Angers, concernant
le service public de la petite
enfance.
C'était un engagement du président
pendant sa campagne.
Il y a urgence, parce que c'est un
sujet très important pour les
familles de notre pays
aujourd'hui.
C'est un frein majeur à l'emploi
et c'est un sujet au carrefour de
plusieurs priorités.
D'abord, la politique
du plein- emploi.
150.000 personnes renoncent à un
emploi pour pouvoir accompagner
leur enfant.
Cela vise aussi à lutter contre
les inégalités de destin.
5% des enfants des familles les
plus modestes ont une place en
crèche contre 20% pour les
familles les plus aisées.
Il y a un enjeu d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et un
enjeu de natalité.
Ces concertations vont nous
permettre de proposer davantage de
solutions aux parents.
Nous voulons assurer de meilleures
conditions d'exercice aussi pour
l'ensemble des professionnels.
Il y a d'abord un volet
qualitatif.
Nous allons assurer des mesures
d'amélioration de l'accueil.
J'annoncerai d'ici
la fin du mois de juin un plan
d'urgence qui reprend les
recommandations du rapport de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales.
Pour le volet quantitatif, nous
voulons faire du bloc communal une
autorité organisatrice en leur
donnant la possibilité de créer
des places d'accueil nécessaires.
C'est un investissement massif de
près de 6 milliards d'euros d'ici
2027.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci à vous.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre du Logement.
Vous faites du logement une
brique sociale.
Vous semblez réagir en convoquant
le Conseil national de la
refondation.
Pourtant, le secteur est
scandalisé.
On est trop loin du compte, des
bonnes trajectoires sociales et
environnementales.
Le CNR ne peut être un point
final.
Nous n'avons rien contre la
démocratie participative, mais
vous devez l'articuler avec la
démocratie parlementaire avant de
prendre une décision.
Nous voulons poursuivre le débat,
nous voulons plancher sur le sujet
et même proposer.
Je préside une mission
d'information qui s'attarde sur la
rénovation énergétique du
bâtiment.
Nous avons constaté un marché
complètement exposé à la fraude,
un manque de visibilité et de
stabilité des dispositifs, une
politique qui n'a pas montré son
efficacité, un soutien financier
souvent insuffisant pour les plus
modestes.
Le CNR ne répond à aucune de ces
questions.
Des solutions existent pourtant
pour déclencher cette envie de
rénover, pour renouer avec la
confiance.
Il faut un accompagnement
technique, financier et social, en
tout cas approprié.
Vous proposez des accompagnateurs,
mais leurs missions sont floues.
Il faut aussi valoriser le prêt
remboursable.
Il reste beaucoup de choses à
faire.
Vos décisions ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux.
Quand allez-vous proposer un texte
pour débattre et intégrer nos
propositions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Monsieur le député Jean-Louis
Bricout, vous avez raison,
l'ambition écologique a irrigué
l'ensemble des travaux du CNR et
je remercie votre collègue
Marjolaine Meynier-Millefert de
son application.
J'en profite pour vous remercier
comme je remercie l'ensemble des
parlementaires pour votre
mobilisation sur les questions du
logement.
Je les invite à rencontrer
l'ensemble des animateurs du CNR.
Leurs propositions sont parfois
moins caricaturales que ce que
j'ai pu entendre aujourd'hui.
Madame la Première ministre l'a
dit hier, je le dis aujourd'hui,
le Conseil national de la
refondation, ce rapport est une
invitation à continuer à
travailler ensemble.
Un certain nombre de propositions
ont été faites hier dans la
continuité de ce qui a déjà été
fait.
1,5 million de chantiers, des
économies d'énergie équivalentes à
la consommation d'une ville comme
Lyon de gagnées, mais il faut être
plus performant.
Il a été annoncé hier plus de 200
chantiers globaux en 2024.
C'est important.
Il a été annoncé une augmentation
importante du nombre
d'accompagnateurs de rénovation,
car les Français ont besoin de
savoir ce qu'ils ont à dépenser et
surtout quels seront les effets
sur leur compte en banque.
Nous travaillons avec Bruno Le
Maire et l'ensemble des instituts
bancaires pour améliorer la prise
en charge.
Nous travaillons aussi sur le
reste à charge et le prêt avance
rénovation, qui est un bon outil
qui permet de multiplier les
effets de MaPrimeRénov'.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Léo
Walter.
- Léo Walter: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Industrie et à
monsieur le ministre de la Santé.
Vous avez déclaré le 3 février que
la mobilisation du gouvernement
était totale pour préserver
l'accès des Français aux
médicaments sur l'ensemble du
territoire.
Le 13 avril, la direction de
Sanofi a annoncé la suppression de
135 postes dans deux de ses usines
françaises.
C'est plus de 10% des effectifs.
Sur le site de Sisteron, un
bâtiment de production sera rasé.
Cela fait suite à la suppression
de 235 postes et s'inscrit dans
une stratégie de long terme de
Sanofi: le démantèlement de sa
filière de principes actifs.
Celle-ci prévoit depuis 2025
l'abandon de la production de 400
molécules jugées trop peu
rentables.
La rentabilité n'est pas l'intérêt
des patients.
C'est la garantie de faire plus de
30% de marge.
Ces 15 dernières années, Sanofi a
touché plus de 1,5 milliard
d'argent public.
Dans le même temps, l'entreprise
supprime 1500 postes, dont près de
50% des postes de chercheurs.
30 milliards de dividendes ont été
versés aux actionnaires.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Industrie, que comptez-vous
faire pour empêcher Sanofi de
détruire des emplois et de
sacrifier sur l'autel des profits
un outil industriel essentiel à
notre pays?
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé,
que comptez-vous faire pour
assurer la souveraineté
thérapeutique française et
rappeler Sanofi à ses obligations
de production et de détention de
stocks minimums de médicaments?
Que comptez-vous faire pour
contrôler l'utilisation des fonds
publics par Sanofi et des autres
et quand allez-vous mettre en
place un pôle public du
médicament, seule garantie d'une
production pharmaceutique efficace
au service de l'intérêt général?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Monsieur le député Léo Walter,
merci de votre question, de vos
slogans, de vos incantations et de
votre volonté, comme toujours...
Comme toujours, vous voulez tout
nationaliser.
Cela fait maintenant 2 ans presque
jour pour jour que le président de
la République a annoncé un
plan France 2030 d'investissement
fort dans la santé afin de régler
le vrai problème auquel fait face
la santé des Français.
Nous souhaitons le faire en
produisant davantage en France.
De plus en plus d'entreprises, y
compris internationales,
choisissent le terrain français
pour s'installer.
Nous l'avons fait aussi sur le
principe actif.
Nous rapatrions le principe actif
du paracétamol dans votre
circonscription, de manière à
reproduire du principe actif de
paracétamol en France.
En ce qui concerne le groupe
Sanofi et les suppressions
d'emplois, vous le savez, innover,
investir, cela suppose aussi
parfois malheureusement de fermer
les installations obsolètes.
Puisque vous connaissez bien votre
territoire, contrairement à vos
voisins qui hurlent, vous savez
que les deux ateliers qui ferment
datent de plus de 50 ans.
Les emplois qui seront supprimés
le seront sur la base de départs
volontaires et de reclassements.
Nous nous assurerons que Sanofi
remplisse les engagements qu'ils
ont faits.
Nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
nous assurer que la souveraineté
sanitaire sera assurée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Géraldine
Grangier.
- Géraldine Grangier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
délégué chargé des transports.
"Les 3,9 millions de motards ne
sont pas des idiots," Bernard, de
mon département, le dit.
"Si l'on monte sur une moto
pourrie, on le paye cash."
Vous devez prendre un décret pour
la mise en place du contrôle
technique des deux-roues
motorisés.
Toutefois, si le Conseil d'Etat
voulait agir en faveur d'une
meilleure protection des motards,
il aurait dû mieux lire les
statistiques.
En 10 ans, le nombre de deux-roues
motorisés a augmenté de plus de
30% alors que le nombre de tués a
baissé de 19%.
Seuls 0,3% des accidents sont liés
à un défaut technique, alors que
30% des accidents comportent un
facteur causal lié aux
infrastructures routières.
Pensez-vous qu'un contrôle
technique payant améliorera la
sécurité et les performances
environnementales des motards?
Avec la mise en place des normes
européennes et l'amélioration des
performances environnementales,
les deux-roues motorisés ne sont
responsables que de 0,5% des
émissions polluantes et
contribuent à fluidifier le
trafic.
Plutôt qu'un contrôle technique
inefficace sur l'accidentologie et
la pollution, les motards
réclament la mise en place de
mesures alternatives afin
d'améliorer la sécurité et la
performance environnementale,
comme l'autorise la directive
européenne.
Ce contrôle technique est une
véritable injustice dictée par
quelques lobbyistes et idéologues.
Laissez les motards s'occuper de
l'état de leur moto et
occupez-vous de l'état des routes.
A quand la mise en place de la
totalité des mesures alternatives
au contrôle technique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci.
Madame la députée Grangier, vous
citez Bernard de votre
circonscription.
J'ai rencontré à
de nombreuses reprises les
associations de motards.
J'ai entendu cet argument.
Celui-ci doit être cependant
nuancé.
On peut dire qu'aucun
automobiliste n'a envie de prendre
une voiture.
Le gouvernement privilégie depuis
de longues années les mesures
dites alternatives au contrôle
technique.
Notre interprétation était que la
directive européenne que vous
citez laissait cette perspective
ouverte.
Quelques pays européens ont fait
ce choix, même si la plupart
d'entre eux se sont aussi mis à
évoluer.
Nous sommes dans un Etat de droit.
Le droit national ou européen est
interprété par le juge.
La loi est votée et c'est le juge
qui interprète ensuite les choses.
Ce n'est ni vous ni moi qui
pouvons dire si les mesures
alternatives sont autorisées ou
non dans la directive.
C'était notre interprétation et
par deux fois le Conseil d'Etat a
indiqué que ce n'était pas la
lecture juridique qu'il fallait
faire.
J'ai engagé une concertation
approfondie avec les associations
de motards pour répondre au
maximum à leurs préoccupations.
Le Conseil d'Etat nous a donné
deux mois pour agir sur ce sujet
définitivement.
Il faudra mettre en place un
contrôle technique, car nous
sommes dans un Etat où nous
respectons les règles
interprétées par les juges.
C'est ainsi que cela fonctionne.
Je recevrai donc ce jeudi les
associations de motards pour
discuter du calendrier et des
modalités avec eux.
Je veux le faire de la manière la
plus respectueuse et efficace
possible.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Emmanuel
Mandon.
- Emmanuel Mandon: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Cette nuit, en Ukraine, un
sabotage a détruit partiellement
une infrastructure civile majeure.
Les conséquences de ce crime de
guerre, la destruction du barrage
de Kakhovka, sont terribles.
La centrale de Zaporijia est
menacée de surchauffe.
Elle est surveillée de très près
par l'agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique.
C'est une catastrophe écologique
sans précédent à l'échelle de
plusieurs régions qui se profile.
Pouvez-vous nous communiquer les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez sur cette catastrophe?
Avons-nous une idée précise de
l'aide d'urgence qui pourrait être
apportée à nos amis ukrainiens?
Au-delà de cela, cet événement
nous rappelle que Vladimir Poutine
crée le chaos et qu'il avait
annoncé cela en pratiquant la
terreur systématique par la terre
brûlée.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont les terres
inondées.
Nous sommes au 16e mois d'une
guerre de haute intensité qui
s'enlise, s'élargit et révèle une
escalade constante dans les
destructions et les menaces.
Nous allons de sidération en
sidération.
L'Europe, par la voix du président
Charles Michel, a annoncé ce matin
que la Russie devrait rendre des
comptes.
Pourriez-vous nous préciser si la
France compte prendre de nouvelles
initiatives diplomatiques à
l'encontre de la Russie pour
dénoncer son action criminelle et
la placer face à ses
responsabilités devant l'histoire?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous avez
raison.
Un nouveau seuil a été franchi
avec la destruction partielle du
barrage de Kakhovka.
Il s'agit d'un acte grave,
inexcusable, odieux, qui aura des
conséquences durables sur la vie
de dizaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens déjà meurtris par la
guerre et qui ont dû être évacués.
Cet acte met en danger
l'environnement et l'avenir des
récoltes.
Il menace aussi de façon
irresponsable la sécurité de la
centrale nucléaire civile de
Zaporijia.
Nous sommes en contact avec le
directeur général de l'agence
internationale de l'énergie
atomique, qui nous a confirmé le
caractère très préoccupant de la
situation, tout en indiquant que
pour l'instant le pire avait été
évité, mais qu'il craignait une
dégradation qui pourrait être
rapide.
Vous savez par ailleurs que
l'Ukraine a demandé une réunion
d'urgence du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations Unies.
Alors que la Russie cherche à
semer le doute sur l'origine de
ces sabotages, nous ne devons pas
perdre de vue un fait simple:
c'est la Russie, et elle seule,
qui porte la responsabilité de
cette guerre.
C'est elle qui bombarde, qui tue,
qui détruit les infrastructures
civiles.
La France et ses partenaires sont
lucides et déterminés.
Nous allons continuer à condamner
les exactions commises par la
Russie, à continuer de lui
demander des comptes et nous
poursuivrons l'accélération de
notre soutien militaire afin que
l'agression russe ne soit pas
récompensée et pour qu'une paix
juste et durable puisse s'établir
le moment venu.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Aurélien
Taché.
- Aurélien Taché: Merci.
Ma question s'adressera aussi à
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères.
Le principal opposant de Macky
Sall au Sénégal a été condamné
dans des conditions troubles et
risque de ne pas pouvoir
participer aux prochaines
élections présidentielles.
La réponse de la France n'est pas
à la hauteur.
Les affrontements entre la police
et les manifestants ont fait déjà
16 morts.
On ne compte plus les arrestations
arbitraires et même les coupures
des dispositifs Internet depuis
dimanche.
L'université de Dakar a été
fermée.
Je me suis rendu au Sénégal le
mois dernier et j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer de nombreux
opposants, ONG ou représentants de
la jeunesse, qui m'ont tous dit
qu'ils ne laisseraient pas le
président Macky Sall leur voler
les élections présidentielles.
La dérive autoritaire dans ce pays
a franchi un nouveau cap.
Cela fait naître une inquiétude
concernant le respect de la
démocratie au Sénégal.
Sans remettre en cause la justice
sénégalaise, des questions se
posent quant à son
instrumentalisation par le pouvoir
en place.
Dès le 27 mars dernier, je vous
avais écrit un courrier sur la
situation politique inquiétante au
Sénégal.
Vous m'avez indiqué que le
gouvernement français serait
attentif au respect du processus
électoral dans ce pays.
Pourtant, ni vous ni le président
de la République n'avez réagi.
Ce silence ne peut que renforcer
un sentiment très anti-français
jusqu'ici très contenu dans le
pays.
Cette parole est pourtant très
attendue par les Sénégalais.
La souffrance va-t-elle se murer
dans un silence coupable?
Free Sénégal!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Les violences
qui ont éclaté au Sénégal la
semaine dernière nous inquiètent.
La France, je suis sûre que vous
l'avez vu, s'est exprimée en ce
sens depuis le début des
événements et vous le savez.
Dans ces violences, de trop
nombreuses personnes ont perdu la
vie, souvent de jeunes personnes,
des enfants.
Je veux adresser ici mes
condoléances à leurs familles et
souhaiter un rapide rétablissement
à tous les blessés.
Nous sommes préoccupés, car le
Sénégal est un pays ami et un
partenaire important pour la
France.
Ici comme là-bas, nous avons une
importante diaspora, des
communautés qui font aussi le
ciment de notre relation.
En tant qu'ami et partenaire du
Sénégal, nous sommes profondément
attachés à la longue tradition de
démocratie, de paix et de
stabilité de ce pays.
En tant qu'ami et partenaire du
Sénégal, nous appelons une
nouvelle fois tous les Sénégalais
à faire preuve de retenue, à
s'abstenir de toute violence et à
résoudre cette crise par le
dialogue.
En tant qu'ami et partenaire du
Sénégal, nous passons ce message
sans relâche, aux autorités comme
à l'opposition, puisque nous
parlons à tout le monde.
J'ai personnellement confiance en
la capacité du peuple sénégalais à
résoudre cette crise, à sortir de
ce moment difficile par un
dialogue inclusif, pacifique,
démocratique afin que les
élections de 2024 puissent se
dérouler dans le respect des
règles de la démocratie et du
droit, et dans la tradition de ce
pays.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-François Portarrieu.
- Jean-François Portarrieu: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Transition
numérique.
L'intelligence artificielle est
partout, dans nos téléphones, dans
nos voitures, dans nos banques,
dans nos hôpitaux...
Elle est dans cet hémicycle avec
la loi que nous venons d'examiner.
Il en a été question à Paris avec
la présence l'autre jour du
créateur de ChatGTP.
Il en sera question la semaine
prochaine au Parlement européen,
où ils vont voter sur le sujet.
Ce sujet ne relève plus de la
science-fiction, mais de la
balistique.
L'intelligence artificielle est
une nuée de projectiles dont nous
ignorons l'impact et la vitesse.
Les développements de cette
technologie vont bouleverser notre
rapport au réel.
Si l'essor de l'intelligence
artificielle générative présente
des effets vertueux, elle
préfigure aussi des risques et des
menaces si l'on n'en perd le
contrôle.
Il apparaît difficile de se
contenter de faire des
recommandations, de lister les
bonnes pratiques ou d'édicter les
principes.
Chaque jour qui passe, les
algorithmes impactent notre
information, notre accès à
l'emploi ou au crédit.
Il s'agit d'assurer l'ordre
démocratique.
Nous risquons d'observer une
défiance généralisée chez nos
concitoyens qui, à terme, sera
susceptible de freiner le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle, y compris dans les
domaines qui pourraient être
bénéfiques.
Cédric Villani, en 2017,
recommandait d'ouvrir la boîte
noire de l'intelligence
artificielle en développant
l'évaluation citoyenne, en pensant
aux droits collectifs sur les
données...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je veux vous
assurer que ma réponse n'a pas été
préparée à l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle.
Nous avons l'ardente obligation de
faire en sorte de voir se
développer en France et en Europe
des modèles d'intelligence
artificielle générative.
Nous en avons les moyens.
De Blaise Pascal, dont nous fêtons
cette année le 400e anniversaire
de la naissance, au récipiendaire
de la médaille Fields
récemment, nous en avons besoin.
Il est hors de question que cette
technologie se retrouve dans les
mains d'intérêts privés qui
placeraient l'Europe dans une
situation de dépendance.
Nous voulons mettre entre les
mains de nos concitoyens des
outils qui soient forgés au feu de
la langue et de la culture
française.
Nous n'avons pas attendu ChatGTP
pour agir.
A la suite du rapport Villani, le
président de la République a
souhaité bâtir une stratégie
nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle, dotée de 1,5
milliard d'euros.
Quatre centres d'excellence ont
été créés, dans votre département.
Nous avons doublé le nombre de
diplômés dans la discipline.
Nous avons 600 start-up
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle.
Cette stratégie nationale est
prolongée dans le cadre de France
2030, avec 1,2 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires pour tenir compte
de l'intelligence artificielle
générative.
Un volet dédié sera annoncé par le
président de la République la
semaine prochaine.
S'agissant de la régulation,
puisque vous en avez parlé, nous
veillons à ce qu'un juste
équilibre soit trouvé.
Le rapport de votre collègue
Philippe Pradal sur le sujet nous
aidera à prendre des décisions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie et la séance de questions
au gouvernement est terminée.